whoa rook tape spawn  we should mention this is the classical  world champion against the blitz world  champion maxima sheila graf  won the blitzworth championship  is the  reigning  champion that discipline  of course i still think magnus is always  a favorite but  it shows you how dangerous maximus  but it's  it's looking bad for him right now hard  to be dangerous if you're out of pieces  i guess the rook b8 is coming  oh  it makes the bishop decide bishop f5  then rook to a8 and now after bishop c6  with c8 and rook c7 he should cope bring  the king first to stop the b-pawn oh no  he doesn't  yeah now it does and uh the a7 is going  to fall  and that's it  handshake  again once again